bonjour manuel Bompard merci beaucoup
d'être notre invité politique ce matin
vous êtes député la France insoumise des
Bouches-du-Rhône on est ensemble pendant
20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Stéphane Vernet de
westfrance bonjour Stéphane bonjour
bonjour beaucoup de sujets à aborder
avec vous manuel Bompard mais d'abord un
mot sur ce qui s'est passé en Italie
dimanche soir en Italie a donc remporté
les élections l'extrême droite est au
pouvoir la gauche s'est effondrée alors
c'est dans un contexte de crise
économique mais les Italiens se sont
tournés vers l'extrême droite et non pas
vers la gauche est-ce que ça vous
interroge est-ce que la gauche qu'est-ce
qu'elle a raté pour en arriver là non ça
m'interroge pas ça me conforte plutôt
davantage dans la démarche qu'on a
engagé en France moi vous savez je fais
partie d'une génération qui s'est
engagée en politique dans le sillage de
la sortie de Jean-Luc Mélenchon du Parti
socialiste c'était en 2008 et je me
rappelle qu'à l'époque Jean-Luc
Mélenchon disait je sors du Parti
socialiste pour éviter que en France se
reproduise
avant en Italie pardon il y a aussi les
pays comme la Hongrie ou la Pologne qui
sont très très à droite est-ce que vous
n'avez pas le sentiment qui a une
progression généralisée sur ce sur ce
continent et ça ça vous fait pas de
nature à vous inquiéter et d'abord c'est
pas qu'une impression vous avez raison
c'est un fait c'est une réalité
électorale que l'extrême droite
progresse partout en Europe bien
évidemment que ça m'inquiète mais moi
mon objectif ou moral c'est pas
seulement de me lamenter ou de
m'inquiéter c'est d'essayer d'agir pour
faire en sorte que ça soit pas le cas en
France et je pense que aujourd'hui le
contact avec les classes populaires avec
les territoires ruraux et on est chez
vous qu'il dit et François Ruffin il dit
ça par exemple je crois pas que c'est ce
que veut dire François Ruffin maintenant
si vous voulez dire alors je sais pas
c'est à lui qu'il faudra poser la
question mais pour vous non il y a la
gauche elle est encore connectée
aujourd'hui elle a poussé encore elle la
réponse aux classes populaires à ces
territoires de route se semblent
délaissés
populaires sur l'ensemble du pays et
quand vous prenez le résultat de
l'élection présidentielle de 2022 par
exemple et que vous analysez les
résultats en fonction de la pauvreté
excusez-moi du terme des communes vous
voyez que Jean-Luc Mélenchon et celui
qui arrive en tête dans les communes les
plus pauvres du pays donc je crois pas
que la gauche est perdu le contact avec
les catégories populaires après la
question aussi la question est de savoir
si la gauche peut encore progresser dans
les catégories populaires c'est une
évidence et donc ça doit être un de
notre travail mais je considère que pour
avancer il faut commencer par pas jeter
le bébé avec l'eau du bain du bilan de
ce qu'on a fait depuis trois campagnes
présidentielles avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon
même quand la gauche est une île bon je
pense aux dernières élections elle pèse
quoi entre 20 et 25% des suffrages
exprimés comment est-ce que vous pouvez
progresser là dessus d'abord je rappelle
que aux élections législatives parce que
j'ai l'impression que ce fait a été
oublié
bien la gauche la nouvelle union
populaire écologique et sociale qui
remporte le premier tour et ça il faut
pas l'oublier maintenant effectivement
il faut continuer à convaincre et
continuer à convaincre que par exemple
actuellement le problème c'est davantage
l'inégal partagé de la richesse quand
vous avez 5 personnes qui possèdent
autant de richesses que 27 millions de
Françaises et de français que c'est là
que par exemple se trouve la solution à
un certain nombre de problèmes auxquels
on est confronté que la question de la
transition d'urgence climatique de la
transition écologique c'est une question
qu'il faut prendre à bras le corps que
la question de la réforme
institutionnelle pour passer à la
Sixième République parce que la
cinquième elle montre année après année
son problème d'un point de vue
démocratique ça doit être une priorité
voilà c'est un débat ensuite et c'est
notre rôle de convaincre mais par
rapport au débat que vous évoquiez tout
à l'heure moi il me semble qu'il faut
d'abord s'appuyer sur ce qu'on a réussi
et ensuite essayer de continuer à
progresser pourquoi pas dans des
territoires où on n'a pas réussi à le
faire c'est il y a c'est pas tabou de
parler de ça mais sans avoir le
sentiment qu'on va chercher à substituer
électorat un autre puisqu'on parle de la
nuque la nuque est dans une zone de
turbulence ces derniers jours dernier
fait en date Julien Bayou qui était le
secrétaire national d'Europe Écologie
Les Verts qui a annoncé quitter son
poste hier ainsi que son poste de
président du groupe de l'assemblée il
est accusé par une ex-compagne de
violence psychologiques alors lui dit ne
pas savoir précisément quels sont les
faits qui lui sont reprochés ne pas
pouvoir défendre car on ne l'entend pas
est-ce qu'il a bien fait pour vous de
quitter son poste ses postes écoutez
franchement c'est sa décision moi je
connais pas précisément l'effet qui lui
sont reprochés j'ai entendu que lui ce
qu'il reprochait c'était le fait de ne
pas avoir la possibilité si j'ai bien
compris de se défendre et ça je peux
comprendre que ça pose un problème c'est
à dire que effectivement dans les
dispositifs qui ont été mis en place en
interne dans les organisations
politiques pour faire face à situation
je pense que ces dispositifs sont
nécessaires par contre ils doivent
respecter un certain nombre de principes
et pour vous aujourd'hui je ne sais pas
de ce que
notamment le du contradictoire c'est la
possibilité de pouvoir s'expliquer sur
les faits qui lui sont reprochés me
paraît être un principe élémentaire je
sais pas si c'est le cas c'est pas le
cas je ne suis pas un membre de la série
interne
qu'il est dû quitter son
passeports il a quitté son poste pour
pouvoir dénoncer ce ce ce cette
situation c'est c'est son choix de le
faire de cette manière moi après il
m'appartient pas de commenter
c'est toujours pas la justice de régler
ce genre de cas bah écoutez si la
justice permettait de régler toujours
tous ces cas ce serait effectivement le
plus simple mais aujourd'hui si ces
dispositifs ont été mis en place au sein
des organisations politiques c'est que
vous avez un certain nombre de femmes
qui ne souhaitent pas aller témoigner
devant la justice parce que elles ont
l'impression que leur témoignage ne va
pas être pris en compte qu'elles vont
être mal reçues au commissariat parce
que ça s'appuie sur des faits un certain
nombre de témoignages gens qui vont leur
dire ah c'est pas très grave laissez
tomber ne portez pas plainte la plainte
sera classée sans suite Vous voyez donc
c'est normal aussi de d'essayer de
pallier assez défauts en mettant en
place des dispositifs internes dans les
organisations politiques maintenant faut
être humble est-ce que ces dispositifs
sont parfaits clairement ils ne le sont
pas est-ce qu'il faut pouvoir les
améliorer oui mais par contre
franchement recevoir des leçons de la
part d'organisation politique qui n'ont
jamais réfléchi sur ce sujet à mettre en
place ce type de dispositif comme ça a
été le cas la semaine dernière je trouve
ça particulièrement choquant la justice
est très lente pour trancher mais est-ce
que vous avez quand même pas le
sentiment que ce type de dispositif a
quelque chose d'hyper expéditif c'est à
dire qu'il suffit de dire qu'il y a un
problème pour que le principe de
précaution s'applique et du coup paf
vous avez vous vous avez vous pouvez
avoir un homme ou une femme politique de
main qui qui voit son son son parcours
suspendu immédiatement quoi enfin moi je
suis pas favorable à l'idée de dire que
parce que il y a un signalement dans ces
cellules doit forcément y avoir un
voyait bien que de fait des factures
c'est ce qui se passe je ne crois pas je
pense qu'on doit être en enfin peut-être
que parfois ça se passe dans certains
dispositifs mais moi je suis favorable
au fait que on assume l'idée et le pas
sur les questions sur ces questions là
de dire que tout fait qui sont reprochés
ne se valent pas et donc tout fait qui
sont reprochés ne produisent pas
toujours à la même sanction qui doit
être le baddhisme généralisé sinon il y
a plus de justice un des principes de la
justice c'est la proportionnalité en
fonction des faits qui sont reprochés il
y a des réponses ou des sanctions qui
doivent être proportionnelles elles
aussi donc voilà je pense que ça doit
faire partie des travaux qui sont
engagés par ces cellules et donc s'il y
a des dispositifs pour avoir des
cellules communes entre plusieurs
organisations politiques par exemple
pourquoi pas parce que
je pense que si ça permet de commencer à
avancer sur des principes communs entre
toutes les organisations politiques pour
que ce sujet ne soit plus l'objet de de
d'instrumentalisation politicienne alors
oui je pense que ça pourrait il y a des
instrumentalisations potentielles
à l'égard de la France insoumise il y a
sans doute parfois des indignations qui
sont
sincères je le conteste pas mais j'ai
bien vu que quand vous avez des
représentant de la République en marche
qui viennent essayer de faire un procès
à la France insoumise sur la question
des violences sexistes et sexuelles
alors qu'ils ont eu des parlementaires
dans leur rampe qui pendant 5 ans ont
siégeait avec ce type de reproche sans
que personne n'y trouve rien à redire
oui je trouve qu'il y a eu des
instrumentalisations politiques au sein
de la nuque il y en a eu aussi notamment
chez Europe Écologie Les Verts je ne
crois pas enfin je sais pas à quoi vous
voulez faire référence en ce qui me
concerne je préfère d'abord me
concentrer sur ce qui se passe au sein
de la France insoumise et au sein de la
France insoumise je ne crois pas qu'il y
a eu d'instrumentalisation politique
parlementaires et la presse régionale à
cette question faut-il que les
responsables politiques se montrent de
plus en plus transparents sur leur vie
privée 69% des Français disent oui et 81
% des sympathisants de la gauche radical
10 oui est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec ça il doit y avoir plus de
transparence non je j'assume même si
peut-être que mon avis n'est pas partagé
j'assume que un responsable politique
c'est pas parce que c'est un responsable
politique que sa vie privée devient une
vie public bien évidemment il doit avoir
un certain nombre de principes
d'exemplarités ça je ne le conteste pas
et de respecter la loi mais mais mais je
pense que c'est pas rendre service à la
démocratie de considérer que la vie
privée d'un personnage politique elle
doit forcément être étalée sur la plage
publique je pense que quand on vote pour
quelqu'un on vote parce qu'on partage
ses idées on vote parce qu'on défend le
même projet de société et pas pour des
raisons liées à sa vie privée une
question sur Adrien katmince qui est en
retrait de ces fonctions à la France
insoumise et également de son poste de
député il est en retrait mais il est
toujours député ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui il touche son indemnité
parlementaire sans pour autant
travailler est-ce que vous comprenez que
ça puisse interroger voire choquer des
Français dans ces temps d'inflation
qu'un député touche son indemnité
parlementaire sans exercice et fonction
écoutez je pense qu'elle est députés de
la France insoumise n'ont pas de leçon à
recevoir de qui que ce soit sur le sujet
vous regarderez les fiches de présence
le travail réel réalisé par les députés
de la France insoumise à l'Assemblée
nationale
et si vous voulez être choqué par ça je
vous propose d'être choqué par un
certain nombre de députés qui n'ont pas
de questions personnelles à régler et
qui pourtant sont absents du travail
parlementaire ça ça peut choquer vous
voyez en ce qui concerne Adrien cadenas
on peut comprendre quand même que une
personne quand elle est confrontée à une
situation personnelle un petit peu
difficile en l'occurrence ici c'est un
divorce sur lequel il a besoin de se
concentrer un peu on peut comprendre que
ça a été un député certes mais ça reste
un être humain et donc on peut
comprendre aussi qu'un être humain de
temps en temps il ait besoin de se
concentrer sur la situation personnelle
un peu difficile pour reprendre vos
termes d'un cadenas c'est quel impact va
avoir sur le la France insoumise on sait
que le parti est un tournant de son
histoire il est il est question de
réorganiser le mouvement notamment de
penser à la succession de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon est-ce que est-ce que Adrien
Catena c'est toujours dans la course
qu'est-ce que ça modifie ou pas dans
dans vos réflexions sur le sujet d'abord
et vous avez raison il y a la volonté
pour la France insoumise de franchir une
nouvelle étape qui vient du fait que on
a très largement progressé on avait un
groupe de 17 députés on a un groupe de
75 députés on a progressé en termes
d'implantation territoriale et donc ça
pose la question pour la France
insoumise de se doter d'une nouvelle
étape j'ai envie de dire de son
organisation pour le reste et c'est pour
ça qu'on le fait pas pour
assurer la succession de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon je sais qu'on nous interroge
en permanence sur ce sujet mais je
voudrais poser la question la succession
à quoi parce que si c'est la succession
en tant que président de groupe à
l'Assemblée nationale ça ne vous aura
pas échappé que cette question est
réglée il y a quelqu'un de la France
insoumise mais certes il était passé la
question que vous me posez c'est
incarnez la France insoumise Jean-Luc
Mélenchon à l'incarner la question que
vous me posez c'est la succession de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon pour la prochaine
élection présidentielle 2020 évolution
du mouvement ça c'est sûr que vous avez
mis sur la table vous-même vous en avez
parlé à Valence dans vos journées d'été
etc c'est ça a été mis en place ça a été
ça a été mis sur la table dans un
certain nombre de meeting Jean-Luc
Mélenchon lui-même elle a dit que il
avait il avait pas l'intention de se
représenter une fois de plus à la
présidence elle fait pas question que
vous me posez donc c'est sûr pour la
prochaine et l'extraction que vous posez
et j'avenir du mouvement il y a pas de
problème et ma question précise c'est le
fait que Adrien cadenas soit en
difficulté quel impact ça sur cette
réorganisation
mais je pense que elle est pas
d'actualité aujourd'hui la question de
savoir qui va remplacer Jean-Luc
Mélenchon pour l'élection présidentielle
de 2027 je pense que la question est
posée c'est et qu'est-ce que fait la
France insoumise aujourd'hui aquarelle
sert et donc je préfère me concentrer
sur ça pour l'instant pour le reste bien
évidemment Adrien cadenas était une est
une des personnalités de la France
insoumise et clairement pour l'instant
il est en retrait donc oui ça change
quelque chose dans dans l'immédiat pour
le reste maintenant la France insoumise
elle est engagée dans les batailles dont
on va parler
trouve que la côte de popularité de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon ça aussi on le voit
dans notre dernier sondage est-ce que
est-ce que quand même Jean-Luc Mélenchon
il est en train de se déconnecter de ce
que la société
ça fait 15 ans que je fais de la
politique avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon à
intervalles réguliers on cherche un
instrumentaliser une crise on me dit que
ça cote de popularité baisse qui les
finit et puis la dernière fois nous a
fait ça au moment des perquisitions vous
avez vous en rappelez Jean-Luc Mélenchon
il a fait 22% des voix le plus gros
score qu'il a jamais réalisé à
l'élection présidentielle bon donc vous
n'êtes pas encore prêt à tourner la page
Jean-Luc Mélenchon
Luc Mélenchon mais en même temps qu'il y
a Jean-Luc Mélenchon il y a une nouvelle
génération qui émerge au sein de la
France insoumise et c'est très bien et
d'ailleurs on peut en rendre grâce aussi
à Jean-Luc Mélenchon pour avoir
contribué à la faire émerger face au
budget vous allez regarder hier la
présentation du budget 2023 qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez comment il est ce
budget du gouvernement d'avoir c'est un
contrairement aux apparences c'est un
budget de d'austérité de compression de
la dépense publique c'est parce que dit
la majorité oui je sais la majorité va
nous dire que ça progresse mais de
protection de la progression d'un budget
il doit s'évaluer à la progression des
dépenses qui sont rendus nécessaires par
l'évolution de la situation quand vous
avez un budget dans un contexte d'une
inflation qui va être de 4 5 6 ou 7 % et
que les dépenses publiques augmentent de
1 ou 2 % en réalité c'est un budget de
contraction de la dépense et il faut le
dire pour les gens qui le comprennent et
le premier énergétique par exemple de
mesure deuxièmement
la rhétorique parfois est intéressante
mais un bouclier vous savez c'est censé
vous protéger un bouclier qui laisse
passer par donnez-moi de la métaphore
15% des flèches et plus tout à fait un
bouclier donc un bouclier qui dit que il
va y avoir 15 % de augmentation des
dépenses énergétiques à partir du 1er
janvier ça s'appelle pas un bouclier et
donc vous avez des gens qui vont subir
une augmentation de 15% des dépenses
énergétiques au premier janvier en ce
qui me concerne je défends une hypothèse
de blocage des prix de l'énergie pour
faire en sorte que les gens puissent
sortir tout simplement parce que ils ne
vont pas pouvoir s'en sortir les gens ne
vont pas pouvoir encaisser une
augmentation des dépenses énergétiques
de 15%. donc c'est un budget qui ne les
protège pas du tout et pour le reste
puisque quand je dis ça on me dit ça
coûte trop cher je dis le gouvernement
fait le choix de s'asseoir sur un
certain nombre de ressources qu'il
serait possible de mettre en place et la
ressource la plus simple à mettre en
place aujourd'hui c'est la taxation sur
les super profits vous savez qu'on a
déposé avec nos partenaires de la nuque
une proposition de loi qui a examiné en
ce moment devant le Conseil
constitutionnel le chiffrage de cette
proposition de loi c'est 20 milliards
d'euros pour l'année 2022 qu'on peut
faire rentrer dans les caisses de l'État
et le gouvernement refuse ça par pur
idéologie et ben moi je le dis si on
veut pouvoir financer un véritable
budget de protection il faut des
nouvelles ressources et cette nouvelle
ressource il faut notamment la prendre
sur les supers
dans Le Parisien qui dit elle qu'elle
plaît pour une redistribution des
profits engendrés par les entreprises
qui ont connu des bénéfices
conjoncturels c'est important en termes
d'acceptabilité sociale dit-elle en plus
elle dit il faut aller vite fait cette
déclaration
puisque vous savez que notre proposition
de loi aujourd'hui elle est signée par
240 parlementaires je propose LeBron
privé de la ciné à son tour il n'y a pas
de dogmatisme ou de sectarisme de notre
côté toutes celles et ceux qui seraient
d'accord pour défendre cette idée de
taxation des super profits à l'échelle
nationale mais une redistribution mais
je veux renvoyer de la convaincre parce
que sinon je sais pas ce que ça veut
dire vous savez une taxe qui fait
rentrer des nouvelles ressources dans le
budget et ensuite une politique de
redistribution ça s'appelle de la
redistribution comme l'appel de CV il y
a le One Piece et c'est important est-ce
que vous êtes prêts en cas de 49-3 à
voter une mention de censure avec le
rassemblement national mais moi j'ai
déjà dit mon point de vue sur le sujet
je j'ai dit que en cas de 49-3 d'abord
nous déposerions notre propre émotion de
censure et que en ce qui me concerne on
en a pas à discuter collectivement ni au
sein de la nuque d'ailleurs ni au sein
du groupe de la France insoumise donc on
le fera mais moi mon avis personnel sur
ce sujet c'est que dans ce cas là il
faut voter l'ensemble des motions de
censure qui serait
parce que Boris Vallot le président
socialiste hier était sur notre antenne
il a dit moi je vois pas avec les
symptômes on en discutera mais moi il
s'agit pas de voter quoi que ce soit de
commun avec l'extrême tu mets une motion
de censure c'est voter non mais émotion
de censure c'est voter contre le
gouvernement parce que je dis que si le
gouvernement sans tête à vouloir
réformer les retraites par
l'intermédiaire d'un amendement dans le
projet de loi de finance de la sécurité
sociale je considère qu'il faudra
utiliser tous les moyens à notre
disposition pour l'empêcher de le faire
tous les moyens c'est quoi bah c'est ça
c'est c'est une motion de censure c'est
voter l'ensemble d'émotions de censure
qui se présente à nous moi je le dis
aussi j'ai pas peur de le dire je suis
favorable dans ce cas là si le
gouvernement s'entête à vouloir passer
en force et en catimini sur ce sujet à
ce que nous déposions de très nombreux
amendements parce que si le gouvernement
ne veut pas de débat je vois pas
pourquoi on le laisserait comme ça
dérouler parce que ce serait une fortune
je pense que ce serait une forfaiture
démocratique de laisser le gouvernement
réformer reporter l'âge de départ à la
retraite par l'intermédiaire d'un
amendement dans le projet de loi de
finances de la sécurité sociale c'est
une méthode cavalière madame Braun Pivet
et contre Lady franchement a dit ça veut
dire que vous n'avez pas d'étude
d'impact sur le sujet Monsieur Bayrou a
dit qui votre est contre à ce moment-là
donc si Emmanuel Macron sortait sur ce
sujet faut qu'il s'attendent à une
réponse par le mentale extrêmement forte
et à une réponse populaire extrêmement
forte et j'en profite pour dire nous on
a mis sur la table organisation d'une
marche contre la vie chère et contre
l'inaction climatique le 16 octobre à
Paris jeudi si le gouvernement sans tête
sur le sujet ça sera aussi une très
grande marche contre le report de l'âge
de départ à la retraite et j'appelle les
citoyens et les stars se préparer d'ores
et déjà il faut que si Emmanuel Macron
s'entête sur ce sujet il est une réponse
ferme et forte de la population
les syndicats ne veulent pas y
participer Yannick Jadot dit il a dit le
dimanche au Grand Jury ben dans ces
cas-là moi j'y participerai pas non plus
je vais pas une marche qui se fait
contrôler syndicats c'est pas du tout
une contre les syndicats premièrement
deuxièmement les syndicats n'ont pas dit
qu'ils ne voulaient pas y participer ils
ont dit qu'à ce stade il n’appelait pas
et il participe pour le moment et qui a
une nouvelle réunion qui est prévue le
lundi 4 octobre qui va permettre de
discuter avec les organisations
syndicales sur leur éventuelle
participation à cette marque nous nous
souhaitons qui participent en tout cas
nous les invitations les invitons pardon
à participer à nos côtés et même s'il
décide de ne pas participer ça ne
devient pas une marche contre les
organisations syndicales il y a
différentes formes d'actions qui sont
prévues dans les prochains jours et dans
les prochaines semaines de mon point de
vue elles sont complémentaires pour le
reste Yannick Jadot exprime la position
qu'il a envie mais Europe Écologie Les
Verts le parti mais bien sûr tout le
monde est le bienvenu dans cette marche
et même madame brun pivel elle est la
bienvenue si elle veut manifester contre
la réforme des retraites d'Emmanuel
Macron on a bien compris que sur la
réforme des retraites ça ne peut pas
être par amendement vous êtes vous êtes
vende debout et on vous entend ce serait
quoi la bonne méthode aujourd'hui pour
réformer les retraites parce qu'il va
quand même bien falloir faire quelque
chose sur le sujet parce que le rapport
du corps montre qu'il y a un déficit on
voit que le
le ministère des comptes publics
comptent sur 8 milliards d'euros brut à
récupérer d'ici 5 ans la fin du
quinquennat on a aussi besoin de cet
argent non alors on a entendu tout et
son contraire sur le sujet d'abord le
rapport du corps il tord le cou à
l'hypothèse du de d'une fuite
incontrôlée des dépenses de retraite je
cite c'est exactement le terme qui est
qui est indiqué dans le rapport du corps
donc il y a pas de problème financière
ensuite
2023 oui et puis après un retour à
l'équilibre à partir de 2040 2030 ou 204
donc on fait rien non attendez moi je
suis pas pour rien faire sur la question
des retraites je vais vous répondre mais
d'abord dire c'est pas vrai qu'il y a
une nécessité urgente de faire une
réforme sur les retraites deuxièmement
j'ai entendu Emmanuel Macron nous dire
il faut armé il faut réformer les
retraites parce que c'est avec ça qu'on
va financer les dépenses de l'école ou
de l'hôpital public mais vous vous
rendez compte de de à quel point ça ne
correspond à rien vous savez que les
retraites sont financées par des
cotisations alors que le budget de
l'hôpital public ou de l'école sont
financés par le projet de loi de
finances sont financés par l'impôt je
disais c'est un mensonge de dire ça il y
a aucun rapport entre les retraites et
le budget de l'hôpital ou le budget de
l'école publique pour le reste moi je
suis en forme d'un peu déguisé de
récupérer les cotisations des retraites
n'importe quoi il fait comme si le fait
de travailler plus longtemps nous
permettrait ensuite de financer
davantage d'investissement dans l'école
et dans l'hôpital et puis dans le même
temps il refuse de mettre en place la
taxation sur les super profils dont on a
parlé tout ça n'a aucun sens pour le
reste bien évidemment qu'il faut une
réforme des retraites il faut une
réforme des retraites pour ramener l'âge
de départ à la retraite à 60 ans et il
faut une réforme des retraites parce que
le rapport du corps il dit une chose de
manière non c'est pas le rapport du
corps mais un rapport de l'INSEE que
j'ai lu dit une chose de manière très
précise le problème auquel on est
confronté c'est la paupérisation des
retraités si on continue comme ça le le
le
niveau de vie pardon des retraités va
baisser de 10 à 15% par rapport au
niveau de vie de la population donc il
faut il faut des pensions de retraite
qui soit plus fortes on a mis deux
propositions sur la table pas de
retraite en dessous du SMIC pour une
carrière complète pas de retraite en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté donc monter
le ce qu'on appelle le minimum
au niveau du seuil de pauvreté vous
voyez qu'on peut faire des choses mais
c'est antagonique avec ce que veut faire
le gouvernement juste un dernier mot sur
les traits puisquare Elizabeth borne
vous a appelé au dialogue au compromis
vous êtes prêt à aller dialoguer quand
même parce que vous avez des positions
très arrêtées mais non mais il y a pas
de dialogue il y a pas de compromis
possible sur la question des retraites
il faut que je fais c'est clair nous on
propose de ramener l'âge de départ à la
retraite à 60 ans Monsieur Macron veut
l'amener à 64 ans je rappelle quand même
64 ans c'est la l'âge de l'espérance de
vie en bonne santé moyen dans ce pays il
y a 25% des hommes les plus pauvres qui
meurent avant 62 ans dans ce pays et
vous allez demander aux gens d'aller
travailler jusqu'à 63 64 65 66 c'est
impossible donc il faut se battre sur ce
sujet merci beaucoup manuel merci merci
d'avoir été notre invité et la réforme
des retraites c'est la Une de
Ouest-France justement aujourd'hui la
réforme des retraites toujours dans le
flou c'est le 16 octobre à la marche et
le message est passé merci manuel bon
pas bonne journée on passe au club
d'État
[Musique]